on the topic of general intelligence i
don't know
how much i've talked to you about it
like what um
do you think will actually build an agi
like if if you look at ray kurzweil with
a singularity do you have like an
intuition about
you're kind of saying driving is easy
yeah and
i i tend to personally believe that
solving driving
will have really deep important impacts
on our ability to solve general
intelligence like
i i think driving doesn't require
general intelligence
but i think they're going to be
neighbors in a way that it's like deeply
tied
because it's so like driving is so
deeply connected to the human experience
that i think solving one will help solve
the other
but but so i don't see i don't see
driving is like
easy and almost like separate than
general intelligence but like what's
your vision
of a future with a singular do you see
there'll be a single moment like a
singularity where it'll be a phase shift
are we in the singularity now like what
do you have crazy ideas about the future
in terms of
agi we're definitely in the singularity
now um we are
coolers of course look at the bandwidth
between people the bandwidth between
people goes up
all right um the singularity is just you
know when the bandwidth but
what do you mean by the bandwidth of
people communications tools the whole
world is networked
the whole world is networked and we
raise the speed of that network right
oh so you think the communication of
information in a
distributed way is a empowering thing
for collective intelligence
oh i didn't say it's necessarily a good
thing but i think that's like when i
think of the definition of the
singularity yeah it seems kind of right
i see like it's a change in the world
beyond which
like the world be transformed in ways
that we can't possibly imagine no i mean
i think we're in the singularity now in
the sense that there's like you know one
world and a monoculture and it's also
linked
yeah i mean i i kind of shared the
intuition that
the the singularity will originate from
the collective intelligence
of us ants versus the like some single
system agi type
thing oh i totally agree with that yeah
i don't i don't really believe in like
like a hard take off agi kind of thing
um yeah i don't think
i don't even think ai is all that
different in kind
from what we've already been building um
with respect to driving i think
driving is a subset of general
intelligence and i think it's a pretty
complete subset
i think the tools we develop at comma
will also be extremely helpful
to solving general intelligence and
that's i think the real reason why i'm
doing it
i don't care about self-driving cars
it's a cool problem to beat people at
but yeah i mean yeah you're kind of
you're of two minds
so one you do have to have a mission and
you want to focus and make sure you
get you get there you can't forget that
but
at the same time there is a thread
that's much
bigger than uh that connects the
entirety of your effort that's much
bigger than just driving
with ai and with general intelligence it
is so easy to delude yourself
into thinking you've figured something
out when you haven't if we build a level
five self-driving car
we have indisputably built something
yeah
is it general intelligence i'm not going
to debate that i will say we've built
something
that provides huge financial value yeah
beautifully put that's the engineering
credo like just
just build the thing it's like uh that's
why i'm with uh
with the with elon on uh go to mars
yeah it's a great one you can argue like
who the hell cares about going to mars
but the reality is set that as a mission
get it done
yeah and then you're going to crack some
pro problem that you've never even
expected in the process of doing that
yeah
yeah i mean no i think if i had a choice
between humanity going to mars and
solving self-driving cars i think going
to mars is uh
better but i don't know i'm more suited
for self-driving cars i'm an information
guy i'm not a modernist i'm a
postmodernist
post-modernist all right beautifully put
you